welcome to this video let's see let's go
for a French and play them the classical
I really don't trust the win over too
much which doesn't mean it mean that
it's a bad opening and it's just that I
don't really know much about it wow
really and this is actually thought to
be to be completely unplayable because
of this quickpwn assault be three Izzy
four that is to play c3 and Knight b6
it's very difficult to to defend again
thurs
now if i pay for this probably wasn't
even though the most precise
continuation let's try to stop stop it a
bit under on the other side okay let's
all the way back and I need to I need to
be quick now so let's see if he mmm
yeah well a force it's not it's not
exactly a mate you can always recapture
with the sea pond after I take one be
three
yeah well this wasn't exactly great play
by me I should have taken a bit of time
earlier because this is really something
know that black can refute outright and
now I'm just were seeing on f7 okay I
need to UM probably give up the the
exchange anyway so would a forum on
yellow I won't get anywhere without this
yeah this is also puzzle just just going
going to a jade and you can always
recapture with the sea pawn now this is
for 96 to protect evade
yeah well talk about unnecessary
problems I mean problems is is far too
friendly for that I'm just lost prowling
the only slight hope is that him for
some reason spends lots of time how to
see it how to do anything without the
smooth and yeah well its got f5 coming
amongst others okay
yeah you can we can even play a play
that probably and the check on f6 is not
bad either interesting
and now it looks weird but maybe this is
good for shock value I don't see what
the look is doing on a it anyway hmm
yeah well if I move it to him then f8 is
comm check
yeah maybe yeah maybe you can just take
it as possible
threatening situ
check hmm strange check maybe it doesn't
matter I'd still i'm surprised i just
got queen e6 as well okay but i can go
to a seven Queenie six king to a son
yeah it's probably good for white anyway
even dad yeah but he probably needs to
do something like that so it is slightly
tricky his King isn't exactly a safe
mcqueeney to is made if you place a
nothing move quite resigned what oh I
don't really understand why why do you
resign white is just better here we can
play Queen e6 and take on a six or not
however I don't not getting the point
the compass saying it's a draw on this
is what so cute at least you can play
Luke a six wow he probably must have
missed something something simple I
thought this move it's not a check wow
I'm completely hallucinating hahaha for
some reason I thought Queenie six is a
check and need to react to that Wow okay
wow that's that's weird yeah but then he
needs to play Roque six after which the
check isn't really helping sure it's
it's a draw probably with the perpetual
I can also just just take and then you
take here and this is this is chance is
the perpetual check check no this is
check not advisable but you can just go
back and draw yeah well we both were
blind I mean I was talking complete
nonsense with Queenie six thinking this
is a check and he just resigned but what
I really really played like like a [ __ ]
was right after the opening I mean long
castles is completely unplayable let's
let's check that maybe it's more precise
to start with c4 Knight b6 and then
before me it just ajust a very a very
dangerous porn roller here maybe this
one just just for example then this this
this is very very dangerous I mean this
even the computer gives us plus 3 4
black just for for an example but the
way I played that it really was it
really was wasn't so great the ith 5 is
probably probably just idiotic I need to
need to get ahead with my own claim
something like that here in case of any
night g5s i also have 98 to defend this
is probably still quite good for black
it's it's it's very complicated but
still my attacking ideas are much much
more realistic than than hear something
okay thanks for watching